well shout out to you I mean you I feel
like I'm always impressed when I see
someone with a beautiful voice also be a
pothead really oh you smoke a lot to
have to be able to sing like that like
yeah sometimes it helped the raspiness
of people voices true if you got the
raspy thing going I I get that you've
also kind of been like uh one of the
go-to like hook people I feel like for a
lot of rappers what has been like your
favorite hook you've cut that wasn't for
your own [__] for my own song a hook
um um I think you know I I did one for
Jeezy it's um Jeezy Ben butcher um the
real Hood songs I just like I like being
the bringing the sugar to the spice or
however you would say like I like being
the sweet voice that comes on like a
real rough neck kind of song um um it's
easy to do it with melodic rappers I I
like to specifically do hooks on like
the thug thug out something well cuz yo
like in the 2000s that was the thing
that was the thing you would have like a
harder with an amazing dope female
singer or male singer and it would be
like a dope record like even back when
like I mean I love Tupac like I grew up
on Tupac my mom loved Tupac so like the
women that he would have on there like
just sing they heart out I feel like if
I was back in that era that would have
been me on the Tupac songs was is Tupac
like your goat my goat yeah who your
favorite I never really said he was my
goat um who's my I mean he is he's
definitely like a fave of M like I I
have a lot of faves that are like OG's
like like Whitney Houston shout to
Whitney yeah um but yeah I love love
love Tupac who's who do you think uh I
think Whitney's probably got the best
voice ever best voice ever um she has a
very like very powerful like what her
one of the best voices Adele there too
um Kiki Wyatt um for sure her voice is
insane of course Beyonce's voice is
insane Beyonce is the goat but that's
like I mean look everybody knew that
Beyonce is like the best performer I've
ever but Whitney's
vocals I just feel like you put a like
we're in a room there's no mics you just
got a belt she probably just command the
whole room like yeah shout out to
Whitney what's your uh what's your
growing up what was like your favorite
top two or three R&B albums top two or
three R&B
albums H do I have to say albums cuz
sometimes I would just pick songs from
albums okay give me those my top two
growing up
um I listen to a lot of now this is only
up for my mom what she would listen to
like I listen to a lot of
um Monica Lauren
Hill um TLC s SWV uh Ashanti and uh
aarie aarie was fire yeah I love I
wanted to be here when I was little
shout out to Ashanti she just
re-recorded her her albums cuz she
didn't own her master so she did a whole
new version of her debut album so if
you're going to stream Shanti stream the
new version yeah go get that she gets
paid off of that yeah and see that's a
beautiful thing I I currently own my
master so that's amazing yeah I was that
something that you got from the jump or
did you have to negotiate that okay from
from the beginning of being signed
that's important yeah very important um
because now you don't have to resing
your [__] in 20 years yeah cuz it don't
it happened I mean Taylor Swift just had
to do it you know yeah that's crazy I
think maybe they had to redo it because
back then maybe it was stricter things
stricter policies there was worst deals
back then oh yeah the record deals back
then were
terrible they were the worst well shout
out to God shout out to you you got the
uh you also had the leverage to ask for
your Masters cuz a lot of artists if
they're brand new they don't have like
you have I came I came in with leverage
when I was get signed because I already
had a fan base for YouTube yeah the
YouTube going yeah yeah I already have a
fan base so if no one else in the world
listens to me my my five million or
whatever percentage of them they're
going to listen to I was going to say
coming in as like a you like someone who
had a YouTube fan base you've done such
a great job of like people well first of
all you have people who know you from
that but you also have people who just
know the music but I feel like you've
kind of been
kind of sole example I think ddg has
done a solid job I'm the female he's the
male but I feel like you did such a good
job of like I don't even think of you as
like that like there's been some
YouTubers making music and the music
sucks and then they go back to YouTube
yeah but you're like to me you're an
artist first now like you're so talented
and the music so high level I I like to
say that I I'm not a YouTuber that
turned into an artist I've I've always
been an artist and just turned into a
YouTuber and now I'm doing what I was
posting it just so happened that like
some people discovered you on YouTu yeah
that was the I guess that was the thing
cuz you know I did American Idol um two
time well I'm going just say one cuz the
first time I didn't even make the first
round but I did American Idol and I
thought that was my way when I was 18 I
thought that was going to be my way to
you know to make it to make it how far
did you get um I think top 40 and they
booted me they were booting groups they
had to get rid of people so I you know
they were tripping yeah I my dreams were
really crushed but I was young and so
then from then I was like I'm not going
to really do music anymore maybe this
industry is not for me maybe I should
just do gospel you know I grew up
singing in church um but then I started
YouTube cuz like I mean I had a I had
got pregnant I had a son it was broke
and like YouTube was you know it was
there there for people who don't know
it's free to like if you have a camera
you have an iPhone you could make a
YouTube channel we doing it off iPhone
yeah and then eventually when you get
that first check you get you a camera
but like I I still say like to this day
um you know I left YouTube for a little
bit but I'm I'm going back you are uh
I'm going back well I used to do like
pranks and and vlo daily Vlogs and
things like that but would you do you
would do like the fake couple pranks or
yeah I would say some of them were
playing cuz it's entertainment like you
know but um I won't do those things
anymore because I just feel like that's
cringey now and because they're
obviously fake yeah I mean no no people
still watch a lot of but a lot of those
like shout out to my guy Mystic who was
one of those they're still fake they
they were so fake and I was just like
God how many times how many times can
you fake cheat on your girl before she
realizes it's not real yeah I mean
that's just like that's the but it
worked but I think that was like that
was an era of YouTube yeah like
everybody knew like no one's getting a
pencil stuck in their eye like you know
what I'm saying but um what are you
going to do now so no I that's what I
was getting to um so I decided to go
back and I don't know why I called the
did a podcast cuz now it's super being
it's like being taken serious so now I
have a responsibility to keep up but so
I decided to take my best friend her
name is dami V who also does music but
um we be having conversations on the
phone and stuff so I decided to just do
do that as like a chitchat girl talk but
so it turned into a podcast and it got a
lot of views and people already reached
out like trying to buy or put it on
their platform list don't sell it yet
yeah yeah I I wasn't going that but what
you should do is do it once a week you
got to be consistent once a week yeah or
or twice a month at the very least so
like I literally this is my I only have
my second um my second one is coming out
tomorrow my seconde yeah so if you guys
can have like a consistent drop schedule
yeah whether it's twice I would I
wouldn't do anything less than twice a
month but if you could do once a week do
once a week but do it for like a year
and then you that'll be another 7 figure
back for you because I mean there's
other podcasts that are not as uh that
aren't very good that are yeah doing do
good some money